well i'm pleased to say that this
morning we are joined by the education
secretary dean sahar we thank you very
much for being on the program with us
lots to get through uh education cost of
living and but i do just want to start
with uh sue gray and this meeting that
was apparently held between sue gray and
between the prime minister
who called that meeting
so two things to say on that one um i
don't know the details of all the
meetings that happened number ten but
what i do know
is that the prime minister has never
intervened in the investigation that sue
grey conducted
he has always wanted her to go wherever
the evidence takes her
i've worked with sue gray i've known sue
gray
i know she has the highest level of
professionalism
and her integrity is unquestionable she
didn't pull her punches in her first
report you remember and then the pm came
to parliament made the changes in fact
in number 10 because the report was
critical of the way number 10 was
operating and the price has made
wholesale changes in number 10
and of course she will decide when to
publish her report
and the prime minister will respond to
that as well the important thing to
remember
in my view
is you know sue gray's been able to go
wherever the evidence takes her and will
decide
how she publishes what she publishes in
her report it's a really really simple
question and obviously you're not going
to be across every single meeting in
number 10. but this is a meeting that
has been in the press since sky news
breaker on friday night so it would be i
think fair of us to
assume that you will have asked a bit of
this to number 10 when you know that
you're going to go and be their
spokesperson this morning the reason i'm
asking who called the meeting is because
initially journalists were briefed that
it was sue gray her spokesperson then
had to come out and basically push back
on that so it wasn't true that she
didn't initiate this meeting so who did
call the meeting all i can say to you is
um
the meeting that took place between sue
great and the prime minister um i can't
tell you uh who called the meeting
because i don't i don't
because did you not ask the question of
number 10 before you came on this
morning or did they just not tell you
the answer no i i tell you what the
answer is the answer is very simple the
answer is the prime minister will never
intervene
in grey's
investigation the prime minister
wants sue grey to to basically go
wherever the evidence takes her and i
don't think ultimately who called the
meeting well
do you say you don't know about it
do you not know who called the meeting
because you didn't ask the question or
because number 10 didn't tell you the
answer no but if if sue gray decides
that um
when she publishes she decides you know
how she's going to deliver her final
report that's a question
but what i'm saying to you is
ultimately
there are two facts that your viewers
need to know one
the prime minister
does not
did not would never intervene in this
report he wants sue gray to publish her
report secondly
i've worked with sue gray i know sigre
sue gray's integrity is beyond question
so you're asking our viewers to accept
that the prime minister did not
intervene in this report right
absolutely right okay absolutely right
and
i just just most of our viewers yeah
most of our viewers would have more
confidence in that assertion if number
10 could be straight with them about who
called this meeting and they are not
being straight who called the meeting
who was saying
you know
that segway's first report didn't pull
its punches but who caught the meeting
you know
that the prime minister
would never intervene in such a
investigation has not intervened has
allowed it to happen
sue grace
you can't question sugray's integrity
because i've worked with you right
you're not questioning your integrity
it's very very very simple you will
factor as i i one i don't know two i
don't know what's in the report right
none of us know what's in the report sue
gray will decide when to publish it and
it will be published that's the
important thing and then the prime
minister will respond to it you know
we're we're getting into there there are
meetings happen every day my diary is
full of business you can ask me a
question you know who put this diet this
meeting in your diary i literally come
on your show so i don't know but it went
in the diary because someone in my team
would have thought this is the right
thing to do right you're sort of
creating this
the people who were creating the air of
doubt is number 10 because there is not
a straight answer to a very very
straightforward question who called the
meeting that's literal
literally tens of meetings go into uh
the prime minister and the secretary of
state's diary
we can have the same conversation about
a meeting that's in my diary so how did
that meeting get in the direction i
don't know because that's the honest
answer the honest answer is that number
10 literally has forgotten who arranged
a meeting between sue gray who was
publishing an explosive report
potentially
into the prime minister and law breaking
number 10 and you were really asking us
to believe that number 10 they just
actually don't know how that meeting got
in the diary
i'm saying to you that what's important
what is material to your viewers is that
sue gray has conducted her report
independently the prime minister's never
ever intervened in her report that sue
gray's integrity and professionalism is
beyond doubt you just said to me you
agree with that that is what your
viewers should be concerned about i said
i wasn't questioning that i was asking
but you are you're saying you're saying
you called them no you opened your
question just now by saying do you
really expect my viewers to have
confidence right if they can't if number
10 can't say who actually uh put the
meeting in the diary i'm saying to you
you can't doubt see grace integrity or
pressure you see me of course i'm not
doubting it but then you go back to the
same question therefore you are casting
doubt over it so let's let's at least
have an honest conversation here about
this i'm saying to you
i don't know what's in the report no one
knows until sue grey decides to publish
it that's the right thing because
actually she's done this and done it
properly she hasn't pulled her punches
on the first report and she i'm certain
she won't be pulling her punches on
second because if i know sue grey she
will deliver that report independent
with respect i'm asking a very very
straightforward question about who
called a meeting between sue grey and
the prime minister that's literal i'm
asking yeah and i've just said to you
right i don't know who called the
meeting what i do know is the prime
minister doesn't
and never never would
intervene in an independent inquiry okay
so grace professionals is beyond doubt
me to go in my diary where if you if i
come on here you say to me how did this
meeting get in i have to tell you the
honest truth is i don't know one of my
officials would have probably put it in
the diary so let's not sort of create
this sort of
air of doubt around some a process that
has been absolutely robust and rigorous
that's all i'm saying
what was discussed at the meeting
i don't know i've just said to you i
don't know but all i would say to you is
sue gray
knows that her
report has to be independent has to be
professional
and i'd that i have no doubt look at the
first report but she didn't pull up on
the first report you've said you've said
numerous times that the prime minister
didn't intervene
how do you know that if you don't know
what was discussed because because i
because i know the prime minister has
been determined from day one and he
shared with that with me with um other
ministers and of course the country um
that he would have sue grey conduct a
report independently he would never
intervene or in any way try and um
influence that report and that is what
sue grey
has done and will publish and then the
prime minister will respond to it
afterwards i don't know what's in the
report right we will find out when it's
published what reason do you think the
prime minister could have for calling a
meeting or not or having a meeting i
should say we don't know who called it
for having a meeting with sue gray
before the report was published
back to what i'm saying to you i if a
meter's gone in the diary um for sue
gray and the prime minister to meet i
guarantee you it's not because the prime
minister wants to influence the the
report um if sue grey
you know meets the prime minister as
civil servants
if you don't know what the meeting was
about because it because i have no doubt
and of cigarette's professionalism and
it's you have faith in sugar 100
absolutely i've known see great i've
worked with see gray there is no way she
would allow herself to be influenced by
anybody do you have do you have faith in
the prime minister as well i don't
influence that absolutely very much look
at the way he dealt with it in in her
first report
i'm sure you'd agree with me sue gray
did not pull her punches in the first
report what the premise did
do he didn't make any excuses he put his
hand up said we've got a problem we've
got to sort out number 10 and he went
forward and actually made the changes
number 10 brought steve barkley in to be
chief of staff brought david canzini
into the team made other changes andrew
griffiths came in to do policy big
changes in number 10 that are delivering
real outcomes for your viewers including
on national tutoring program which is on
the front page of one of the nationals
today 1.2 million blocks of tutoring for
children to make their recovery 6
million by the end of this parliament of
course the cost of living that we are
dealing with a global battle against
inflation 22 billion in the next 12
months that's helping people and the
chancellor's reviewing
what more we can do as we see
more of the data coming in on the global
battle against inflation which the us is
battling and the europeans are battling
a big agenda in this government 38 bills
in the queen's speech we're delivering
against that got a school's bill it's
going to mean every child will have a
great education wherever they live with
a great teacher in a classroom at the
right time in the right place for them
that's what we're focusing on let's um
talk about the cost of living at crisis
and the sunday times reporting today
that rishi sunak is planning a windfall
tax on energy companies
which could mean that they get lower
rates if they increase investment is
that something that you would support so
we will look at all the options and i i
with the chancellor and the prime
minister the cabinet will look at every
option let's just think about your
the question of investment so if you
take what um shell are planning to do 25
billion pounds of investment in
renewables in green um bp 20 billion
they both already paid double the
corporation tax the corporation tax at
40
compared to what other sectors of the
economy pay um
there is it's not a
a um zero cost option why do i say that
because uh if you apply a windfall tax
they will probably have to reduce or
take away their dividend who receives
the dividend pensioners through their
pension funds right
investment
has to be
real which is what i think rishi will
demand of all these companies and to see
a road map towards that investment we're
not taking any options off the table the
important thing to remember is the 22
billion the next 12 months is making a
difference so in april the 150 pounds um
council tax rebate went to people's
accounts in october another 200 pounds
uh to bring down their uh electricity so
just to go back on the windfall tax
because it's quite interesting you know
in january you spoke about the windfall
tax saying that it's never going to cut
it but it feels like perhaps
if there are discounts available to
encourage investment
your position could change is that fair
sort of summary of where you're at so
i think as i said to you we have to be
very careful and very sort of clear-eyed
on this that there is no uh you know uh
zero cost options because
if you
have a windfall tax um in the way labour
were proposing and i think they were
closing up 28 billion but if there are
but if there are perhaps things that
would encourage investment you would be
prepared to look at it a bit more
closely so we want to see their
investment but also just remember it's
pensioners who
basically get the dividend from these
companies and if they're going to cut
their dividend because they've had a
windfall tax then that'll make a
difference to pensions as well so there
are no no um you know easy options here
but the one thing we are determined to
do is be on people's side talk on this
on this and i just want to read you part
of the sunday times uh story they say
that downing street is concerned that
simply funding pain relief handouts to
households struggling to pay bills will
quickly be forgotten by voters instead
they want billions of pounds diverted to
long-term surgery that will boost the
economy for years to come
it sounds a little bit this is obviously
from the sunday times but it sounds a
bit dismissive doesn't it um pain relief
handouts because these are people who
perhaps wouldn't vote for the
conservatives anyway
those pain relief handouts could make a
real difference to people really
struggling couldn't they well first of
all no one i have heard speaks in this
way um to
that report and sometimes so i don't
recognize that secondly
what rishi has done is to effectively
deliver 22 billion in 12 months of help
um if you look at what we're doing um
in july
there is a tax cut because we're raising
the national insurance threshold for 34
million people 34 million people will
get 330 pounds more per annum because of
that change what we've done for those
who are really struggling those on um
universal credit is the taper um
increase means they have an exercise the
rise in as you know the rise in
universal credit is far far below the
rise of inflation at a 40-year high it's
very difficult for us but take the taper
that's a thousand and then on top of
that the rise in the national living
wage is another thousand that's two
thousand pounds of help that's gone in
local government councils know
which families i can tell you from my
own local authority that are really
struggling with the weekly shop with the
utility bills we've increased the amount
of help to a billion pounds not money
getting out the door now but of course
rishi will keep looking at this we will
see more data coming through we are in a
global battle against inflation you know
that because you see it in america
you're seeing it in europe right and
when
he
finds the best way to target the help to
those people who really need it he will
make an announcement i'm certain of it
and you think it will be before the
summer well as i said we keep an eye on
this and we're not complacent that's why
i worry about some of these reports
because i don't recognize this language
it sounds like people sort of talking
about this uh in some somehow oh well
you know we might need to do something
no we are determined to be on people's
side okay um if the government is to
increase support you need to find
savings uh some pretty hefty cuts to the
civil service on the way is it true that
you've modeled cuts of up to 40 in your
own department
so we're looking at everything um in my
um uh settlement is is that true about
modelling cuts so we we
we will look at all options the
important thing to remember so yeah so
hear me out because it's important
because you know
these are people's lives right i've got
great civil servants who are doing great
work in my department on my three
priorities on skills
t-levels will be as famous as a levels
right on schools every child to be in a
great school wherever they live in the
country with a great teacher and on
families we're building family hubs in
half of england's local authorities
i need my people to basically be
focusing on my priorities so the way we
shape the department i've got 8 000
people we're going to drop to about 7
150 because that's part of what we've
done in the
spending review settlement it's about 11
to 12
decrease already but we'll look at where
else we can make savings across
government because actually
we are servicing a debt today the debt
servicing is 83 billion pounds a year
last year you used to be 20 billion this
is where you've got to ask labor who's
going to come on next which i will
they're going to borrow
is the 40 figure accurate so we're
looking to model 10
we're above that already 20 30 40 we
will model across that
the the thing to be aware of is you know
my focus
is to deliver outcomes what your viewers
want is by the end of this parliament
i've delivered a great school in every
constituency for every child the right
time the right place for them i've
delivered on the skills agenda
big skills agenda we're going to stand
behind every adult if they want to
retrain a reskill at any time in their
life 37 000 pounds of
investment they can pull it off as a
whole or in modules in the lifelong
learning entitlement but what i'm saying
to you is
i've got to shape my department my
people right to deliver those things
i can't go to a place where i would
actually impact delivery that's my
message to my team and of course
to the nation ultimately now you gave a
uh interview to the times uh last week
that you said britain should be very
proud of its private schools and that
oxford and oxford and cambridge
admission should be based on merit and
evidence
rather than tilting the system away from
children who are performing
so do you think there's a risk that the
system is being tilted away from private
school pupils so let me explain that
yeah what is merit if there are two
students one has gone to my
brilliant state schools and they're
getting better every day and one has
gone to an independent school they get
the same
set of results at a levels
then actually the university should take
the boy from the state school why
because he's had greater challenges to
overcome to get the same results what i
don't think you do you don't level up by
dragging people down our independence
sector you look at what king edwards
school foundation is doing in birmingham
where they actually run independent
schools and
state schools in one foundation what
eaton is planning to do with the star
academies um where they're going to
build three sixth form colleges in
places like oldham in westminster in the
areas that need that
investment in education i want to bring
everybody together right you you don't
succeed by delivering a great outcome
for every child by actually attacking a
part of the system i don't want to
attack independent schools they do a
great job they're joining us on this
journey more than school in oxford is
already looking at where they can
partner with their local authority and
form a trust that's a great thing let's
celebrate that you're talking about
merit i guess the problem that some
people would argue is that because so
many private school pupils go to the top
universities that isn't on merit and
actually the landmark report the 2014
report
analyzing 132 000 students over three
years saying that state schools with the
same results much more likely to gain a
2-1 or a first degree so a boy who gets
bbb at state school was just as likely
to get a two one or a first as a private
school boy with abb so tilting the
system some would say actually that is
fair no i tell you what's fair is i have
to hold myself
and
my team in the front line to say
we can do as well right we can i've
already seen it i've evidenced it in my
white paper there are great families of
schools in high performing multi-academy
trusts around the country i went to
catmo's trust in rutland the other day
right they delivered great results you
still sent your children to private
school though i i hear that was a that
was a parental decision i have to make
that with my wife i don't make that on
my own and i say to you we have great
independent schools they're joining us
on this journey to create real
improvement for all of our children but
the way you do that is by improving the
state system look at what um catherine
bill bersing is doing with michaela
she's got a fantastic weather program
tonight on itv i know it's a different
channel but people should watch what
has been able to do right look at
catmo's um
multi academy trust look at dixon's star
academy um uh the the brilliant phil
harris in what he's done with harris
academies right and smaller schools
hammersmith academy a single academy
trust with gary kiniston delivering
great outcomes he's got 60 people
premium yet he stretches every child to
the best of their ability and knows that
there is no glass ceiling you smash
through it and you get to oxbridge you
get to wrestle group you get to other
universities or you do an apprenticeship
you do a t level and a degree
apprenticeship we now are building
many many runways for people's careers
to take off on not just the traditional
runway that's a good thing and
everyone's joining that journey
including independent schools let's
celebrate that just got one question to
squeeze before i let you go i'm not sure
if you're aware of the story of raheem
bailey this is an 11 year old boy who
lost his finger when he was fleeing from
racist bullies allegedly
he was beaten kicked pushed to the
ground allegedly his finger was then
amputated after it was caught in a fence
when he was trying to run away i just
want to get your reaction to that story
and if we're doing enough to tackle
racist bullying
it's sickening
we always need to do more
i suffered bullying when i first arrived
on these shores i couldn't speak english
um and it was hard and you know
i remember my first experience that
my first school was holland park school
being chased around the park as a sort
of
entertainment for bigger boys and then
throwing me in the pond dunking me head
down in the pond pretty horrific for a
child who just arrived on these shores
and you think that was a racist element
well i don't know
it was a long time ago but i've
certainly
been
at the receiving end of other races uh
um
you know slurs words whatever you know i
was called the pacquiao school i had to
explain that if they mean i'm from
pakistan i'm not from pakistan i'm
actually from a place called iraq and
i'm kurdish of origin it's called
kurdistan
it's a horrible thing and i am
determined to stamp it out as i am
determined to stamp out anti-semitism in
our schools or in our universities
there's no place
for racism
anywhere in our society let alone in
education thank you for sharing your
personal story i'm sure there'll be lots
of little boys and girls who will find
it quite you know inspiring to to hear
someone overcoming that so thank you
very much
nadeem zahawi there the education
secretary